Perpetual motion machines are badly named.
A true perpetual motion machine doesn’t
just keep spinning forever:
if you were to set an object spinning out
in intergalactic space,
in some ideal true vacuum, it would keep spinning
forever.
You just wouldn’t be able to get any useful
work out of it.
If someone actually built a perpetual motion
machine, a true one,
it would give out more energy than is put
in:
enough to overcome friction, enough to overcome
air resistance,
enough to keep going until mechanical failure.
And like a wind turbine,
it’d let you take some of that extra energy
for your own use.
There are, obviously, some physics objections
to this.
The laws of thermodynamics always hold true.
This here is a device made by Thomas Young
in 1807.
It is the original, two centuries old
from the archives of the Royal Institution
in London,
which is why I have to wear gloves to touch
it.
It’s an unbalanced wheel,
and there have been many perpetual motion
machines like it.
There was a giant one in Los Angeles in the
early 20th century,
advertising a café: and according to Popular
Mechanics,
it kept going until there was a city-wide
power cut.
And there was an inventor in 1829 who was
sure
that a carriage with conical wheels
would roll around the world “‘till time
shall be no more”.
They all work on the same principle:
cheat the centre of gravity so it’s always
on one side,
constantly unbalanced in the same direction.
In this case, if you draw a line down the
middle,
there are more ball bearings on one side,
so that side should be heavier,
and when one gets near the top...
...it rolls over, so that side over there
is constantly being pushed down.
This doesn’t work, obviously.
And that’s why Thomas Young built this machine:
to demonstrate that it’s impossible.
There may be more ball bearings on that side,
but the ones on this side are further away
from the centre.
No matter how much you complicate it,
this wheel will just rock back and forth
and eventually settle where the centre of
gravity is lowest,
or where friction stops it.
But imagine if perpetual motion machines did
work.
Which isn’t difficult to imagine, apparently:
there are all sorts of snake-oil companies
who successfully sucker investors into giving
up surprising amounts of money,
and then never produce any actual proof of
a working prototype.
There have been so many attempts that both
the US patent office and the UK "pay-tent" office
refuse to even entertain the idea of perpetual
motion machines.
Now, you can argue physics and thermodynamics
all you want,
but there’s a more common-sense argument
against perpetual motion machines,
against the idea of free energy.
Because regardless of how it’s powered,
whether it’s an unbalanced wheel or something
else,
if you have a magic box that can give out
more energy than it takes in:
what happens if you use a small one to power
a bigger one,
and so on, and so on, and so on?
You could start with something the size of
a grain of sand,
and rotate the Earth with it.
Or what happens if you plug it into itself?
If you have something that multiplies the
energy you put in...
then after a few seconds, you’ve got a bomb.
Thank you very much to the Royal Institution!
Over on their channel I’m debunking three
other types of perpetual motion machines
along with someone from their team.
Go check it out!